so
a lot of people have been asked
she's morphing into something really
yeah her brother
horrendous her brother so abby shapiro
but a lot of people
a lot of people been asking her no but
it's not just turning into her brother
she's her how do you okay look
i'm gonna be delicate here here we go
how do your
more prominent features let's say
become more prominent in your 20s and
30s like i thought by the time you were
a teenager and you hit your early 20s
we've pretty much got an idea of what
you're going to look like
but she's morphing into a pterodactyl so
mercy is saying how did your nose get
bigger
she's turning into a pterodactyl so
this video is uh the title of it if
is uh why aren't i more religious
they're accusing her of not being as
religious as her brother seriously he's
been getting a lot of people saying like
oh you're not as religious as ben hello
classic crew and welcome to today's
oh the name of her her fans are the
classic crew
video where we're going to be talking
about my journey to becoming
more observant as a jew i
hate her over enunciating i want a
[ __ ]
that that makes me angrier than any
other thing about her that the over and
li listen close to her over enunciating
of words it's bothering me
hold on i'm going to turn off the zoom
screen so i could jerk off
[Music]
a couple of days ago i saw on my channel
a comment that i thought about they keep
talking about my milkies
and going num nom nom nom nom nom nom
nom what does that mean i'm not really
sure
it was really important and interesting
important you know you see what i mean
that's gonna bother me really annoying
talk about wanting to be more orthodox
you talk about wanting to become more
observant as a jew
so okay folks if you keep making fun of
my sister you're gonna get a knuckle
sandwich
okay is that what you want you want a
knuckle sandwich
this really is like if ben shapiro and
laura loomer had a teleporter accident
like if we had a ben shapiro laura
loomer two vicks episode
[Laughter]
a loompiro episode i don't know and
jadaway goes at the end [ __ ] it we're
going to kill it
the episodes the episode's 20 minutes
long yeah and it's like yeah we're just
gonna kill him
why aren't you just doing it and i
thought that was actually a good
question okay folks you keep sending me
emails to my daily wire account about my
sister tits and it started
and actually you keep also sending my
sister's kits can you please stop doing
that okay it's very awkward folks
question i thought it was important for
me to address
because uh mark syracuse is calling it a
juvix
perfect remember that remember that
remember that [ __ ] voyager episode
juventus of course it's the one of the
worst of all time of course i remember
it yeah they sent they sent laura
loomer and ben shapiro on an away team
and then they got stuck in a nebula
cloud and they came back as juvix
[ __ ] and they came back looking like a
ferengi for some reason
about on my channel a lot how important
it is to be religious
and how important it is to have faith
and i also talk about the fact that i
grew up
orthodox but that at this point my
husband and i
are not observant so even though we
believe orthodox is the correct way to
practice
and that is the correct form of judaism
we ourselves are not in a place yet
of practicing everything as we should
translation
we love bacon and we don't want to
commit yeah
we still want to have all the benefits
of the culture but we're going to kind
of lay back on all of the i don't know
standards and rules another translation
we like to go out to steak
to steakhouses on saturday night
they don't use a blanket with a hole in
it no no no are you kidding me
i think she's wild i think i think i
think abby is
[ __ ] wild we're very open about this
because i don't want anyone getting the
wrong impression about what we do
we are not keeping all the laws we are
not keeping the practices
as strictly as we should and i think
that it's real and also my brother
is a nerd and i don't want to be
compared to his nerd mark ass
yeah i'm never going to out brother so
i'll
it's like being the rock's brother and
being like i'm going to be a wrestler
yeah i know you're not going to just no
you're not to be open and honest about
that stuff because i want you to know
that i'm on a journey just like everyone
else
but there is a good reason for why jacob
and i haven't already become
completely observant i i gotta see what
the reasoning is
and i want to share that with you guys
today so if you haven't already i would
love if you would consider subscribing
to my
sub stack newsletter if you do you will
get access to exclusive content
like two exclusive videos every month
okay on a trampoline yeah i was gonna
say wait what kind of videos are we
talking about here
i swear to god because if it's you
cooking in that 1950s meme girlfriend
dress
i'm not interested and don't forget if
you sign up you get you get my free
leftist milkers mug
weekly articles live streamed q and a's
as well as how about some live stream
tnas am i right yeah seriously
unless one of those videos is you bent
over and you're doing the thing where
you like do a dildo but where the shot
is from behind i'm not interested
yeah unless you're doing some aaron
andrews squats in a hotel room
home care content pitch contests
and you will get all of this just for
seven dollars a month but if you sign up
for the
what seven bucks a month seven bucks a
month for exclusive
abby shapiro content and none of it
involves tits or [ __ ]
the unmitigated goal of this woman
entire year
you will get two months for free so i
would love if you would consider
subscribing at classically
classicallyabby.substance.com
or head to the link in my description
box but now that that's covered
let's get into it so just to give you
guys a little bit of history if you
didn't already know
i'm jewish i grew up orthodox i grew up
in a religious
jewish home i went to jewish day schools
and
when i was in my master's program i
became less
religious and i talked about this in
another video which i will link
up above which means which means she
partied in college
yeah congratulations you're literally
every person ever
uh my husband on the other hand grew up
reformed so he really didn't have
much of a background in any of this and
when the two of us met
i was kind of becoming less religious he
was becoming more religious
and we decided that we wanted to become
orthodox together
but that was going to be a process
because for him
there is quite a bit of information that
he needs to learn
and for me i had to understand my
relationship
with god no no no see that if you okay
the excuses that they give that she's
giving it's
it's that if you want to become orthodox
you could just start
right now you could start today
look i'm a fat guy and i've done this so
i know exactly what she's doing it's
like i'll start my diet on monday
monday comes along you're like oh but
yeah i'm too lazy today i'll start my
diet next monday
she's doing the i'll start my diet in
the new year's thing
just do it or don't yeah it's like you
know what i'm going to do what i do
like yeah you're right i'm not going to
stop smoking until i'll do the weekend
because i've got the weekend off i can
enjoy it and then like monday comes
around and you're like all right i was
going to quit today and then you're like
i'm in a rush i'm stressed i got to go
do three shows today you know you're
running around the next thing you know
you smoking again
so i know all the laws and the rules but
i wanted to have a better relationship
to my
creator and i wanted to make sure that
whenever i kept
the laws and rules more strictly i was
doing it because i understood it and
because i accepted that upon myself
rather than feeling
like it was something i had to do that i
just she is exhausting
it's it's it's jesus [ __ ] christ
imagine living with this get to it
so a lot of the time people will ask us
why aren't you just observant
right now why aren't you just that's
what i just asked yes please let me know
keeping awesome
this is a woman that you cannot
cannot enjoy a moment of a football game
or a tv show around
this is one of those people that has a
constant
unwavering nervous personality and never
stop
it's like a female ben shapiro would you
now probably not because again she's
starting to
morph into a pterodactyl but probably
now yes still but
i mean she's a few years away from
looking like an extra on the set of
dinosaurs
okay come on
now and i think that's a great question
so i do have a few reasons for why jacob
and i are not
get to it observant as of now and i want
to show you time stamp where are we at
we're at 3 16. three minutes and 16
seconds she said and now i want to share
with you this is the third time she said
yes
so the big reason that jacob and i
aren't but first
i want to tell you guys about blue apron
okay folks i can't eat it because it's
not kosher
but all these cattle that work for me no
she can though oh she could do whatever
she wants
yeah she can she's like yeah i'm gonna
tell you about blue apron i eat it
because
uh i actually am a hypocrite great
friends by the way royce thank you thank
you
oh god look at that one she's looking
good
is that we don't want to jump into it
before we're ready and then
have a backtrack situation a situation
where we jumped in too quickly took on
too much and then
you get overwhelmed and you start oh my
god it's not that [ __ ] difficult you
don't do things on saturday and you
can't eat certain things
she's making it seem like it's this big
deal it's
not that hard i mean yeah there are
actual people like that do it just so
they can have abs
right like aren't there people that just
have dietary restrictions because they
want to look nice
ah yes the rich boss yeah you know
there's plenty of vegans out there who
don't have any relatives that run the
banks
and this happens a lot of the time to a
lot of different people
if you just take on too much especially
without communal support which is
part two then you just won't
end up keeping things you will start
feeling overwhelmed you will start
feeling resentful
and you just will stop keeping things so
instead
of jumping in and keeping everything all
at once
you know what i love too is i love these
all these [ __ ] like counseling like
these
people like abby shapiro who like get
married and they've been married for
like a year or two and they're already
doing a show
about like advising couples and it's
like the
[ __ ] balls on you facts don't care
about my sister's titties folks
it would be like me i've said this
before but it would be like me going to
the gym
and starting to do videos where i'm like
now i'm going to show you proper form
on how to do squats but like the way i
look just with my very limited
experience
this is how you do it folks it's like no
you should be
watching videos on this topic not making
them lady
you just started doing this on
deliberately that's something that we
chose it's something we understand and
it's something that we
believe in and this is especially
important for my husband because
he grew up really not keeping any jewish
laws so for him to take on
everything all at once would mean that
he would really have to do a
180 from everything he knew growing up
so right now what he eats bacon he has
tattoos like
again the laws are there right
you you do it or you don't but this
seems like a whole video about excuses
why
she doesn't want to be as jewish as her
brother
and honestly if you had any questions
just call your brother
yeah isn't he like the king of them
and i would be david i want for him
to have the best opportunity to actually
love and understand and keep
all of the jewish laws because there are
many jewish laws we have 613
commandments
oh my god it's like the ferengi rules of
acquisition it just doesn't end
yeah see we have 10 bing bang bong yeah
we're done
don't eat bacon don't use an elevator on
saturday
i mean what are the other ones you know
[ __ ] your wife through a [ __ ] hole uh
no shellfish i'm i'm trying to go off my
top my head you know tattoos
uh don't lend anybody money the ten
commandments rules it's like
just don't kill anybody don't steal just
don't be an [ __ ] kill jesus
i don't remember all the rules i don't
remember all the rules there's a lot of
rules a lot of rules
look i can't anymore i would love to
play more of her but i'm i just can't
i'm tapping out i'm tapping out i can't
i i'd rather watch ben i hate ben but at
least he gets to his points quickly
you know holy [ __ ] abby all right you
like bacon we [ __ ] heard you
imagine making an entire video on why
you're not doing something
right